يختلفوا معها كثيرون بسبب ارائها الكرويه
المتعصبه فهي ليست مجرد مشجعه بل تنتقد
اللاعبين وتلقي جام غضبها على المدربين
سماحه صلاح 11 المشجعات لكره القدم في
السودان يتابعها كثيرون من رواد مواقع
التواصل ويتفاعلون معها سلبا والجمال
احيانا تواجه الانتقادات بسبب رفض البعض
دخول المراه مجال كره القدم لعبه او حتى
لتشجيعها لكن سماحه من اسره الرياضيه
معروفه فهي حفيده لاعب الهلال السوداني
السابق مكي اسماعيل وهي الان عضوه في قطاع
المراه لنادي الهلال السوداني الاعلاميه
الرياضيه والممثله السودانيه سماحه صلاح
ضيفتنا في صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
كلنا منتظرين يوم الاحد يا معبره الهلال
يوم تاهل الهلال الناس كلها من بدري دي
كلها من الظهر وانا اول وحده حكون
هناك نكون مع الهلال سند الهلال
[موسيقى]
يا شيخ عليك الله انت مدرب اقسم بالله على
تاريخ الهلال كلها
استغفر الله العظيم
شكرا لكم
تلعبوها عليكم الله طريقه
ومدريدي فايز على برشلونه
[موسيقى]
الخرطوم تنضم الينا نشيطه رياضيه سماح
صلاح يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه
رياضيه ولكن كذلك نشجع متعصبه واشهر
مشجعات سودانيات حدثنا اولا عن سر عشقك
للكره المستديره
السلام عليكم صباح الخير عليكم
منتخب السعوديه بفوزهم امس على منتخب هو
مرشح لمونديال
لمونديال غدا الارجنتين
بصراحه رفعوا راسنا كلنا عرب في الف مبروك
لمنتخب السعوديه اا نرجع لاسالك انا عشقي
لكره القدم من جديمك كده لسه لاعب الهلال
السوداني ودرسنا الحب الهلال خلاني كيف
نحب الهلال السوداني العظيم
اها طب يا سماحه انت اسمك سماحه بس عندك
تعصب كروي كيف
الهلال السوداني التعصب طبعا اكيد احلى
حاجه هو فاكهه
الكره ما بيحلى الجو الكوره الا لما يكون
في اشخاص متعصبين كل فريق عنده خصم من
المشجعين بحضروا مع بعض
التعصب طيب سماحه بدنا نفهم منك يعني
الكثير بينتقد البنات لما يشوفوا
المباريات يقولوا لهم ما خصكم طب سمح كيف
بلش معاك
اه صراحه في السودان هو نادر تلقي يعني
تلاقي بنات بيحضروا الكوره بيتعصبوا
للكوره
فكانت يعني ما حدا سهل انه تطلعي وتتكلمي
وتنتخبي اللعيبه وتتكلم عن المدرب فحتى في
مشجعين كانوا
بنستقدوا الحاجه دي انه كيف بتطلع بتتكلم
لكن طبعا دائما حبي للهلال ففي ناس بعد
ذاك الحكايه لانه انا من الاسره دي لا لا
الان في سودانيات يعني كثار بيشجعوا
بيشجعوا الكره بتشجع المنتخبات بيطلع
وبيتكلموا زي زمان طيب اذا ما زي زمان انت
يا سماح تلعبي فوتبول
هيك هوايه
ههه اوكي
كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه يعني
تحصد تفاعل كبير على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي من قبل سودانيين متعصبين
لانديتهم كمان كيف اااه تقبلين هذه الردود
خصوصا السلبيه منها
انا من حبي للهلال الفريق الهلال السوداني
من عظمه فريق الهلال
يعني انا بطني لما اطلع اتكلم لمصلحه
مدربه كان فاشن
لعيبه ما عملوا حياتي للفريق فبطلع بتكلم
الهلال
يلعب
ما بنتدخل في التشكيله لكن في مرات
بتستدعي ان انا نطلع من الكاميرا طب سماح
بما انه عندك همم كثير انتماء رياضي
واحتمام رياضي اليوم كيف تقيماتك
للمونديال بشكل عام
والتوقعاتك للفوز
اه طبعا اول يعني الفريق قطر خسر مباراه
اول حاجه لكن بنهنهم على الافتتاح اللي
تعمل بنهنهم على الانسانيه اللي قدموها لك
دول العالم قدمت عادات وتقاليد لكل الدول
اا بهني كمان القارئ الصغير غانم اا كيف
علمنا الصبر علمنا انه الناس تصبر على كل
المصيبه
واصبحوا قدوه لكل الاشخاص الان
ماشي بصوره بصوره يعني بصوره رابطه شديد
عندنا بالسوداني بنقول كده
فانا بتوقع طبعا البرازيل لي الان ما لعبت
انا بالنسبه لي المونديال لسه ما العب
لانه انا بشجع منتخب البرازيل فانا بتوقع
البرازيل انه الموسم ده رغم انه امبارح
فرنسا كانت تاعبه كوره حلوه وفاته لكن بس
يعني بتوقع على البرازيل الموسم ده تكون
هي بطله مذيعه كاس العالم
لكره القدم انت ولماذا لا نراه منتخب
السوداني الحبيب في المنطقه
لا زي ما شفنا امبارح هلا منتخب السعوديه
انه لعب كيف الكره عايزه القطار في
الميدان الكره عايزه اهميه كبيره في الكره
الكره عايزه اعداد استعداد ااه
ما بنكون كمان الملك فيصل الملك الملك
سلمان انه هو يعني شال شال الدخل من
اللعيبه فقال لهم انه انتم امام منتخب
منتخبات كبيره لكن العبوا لنا من اجل
الاستمتاع كان منهم الضغط فانا بتمنى من
المنتخب السوداني انه اول حاجه يعني
محترفين اهم حاجه المحترفين اللي في
السودان عندنا محترفين همم مفترض يجنن
علشان يلعبوا الحاجه الثانيه انه اهم حاجه
الاستعداد استعدوا استعدوا للمباريات احنا
كان يعني جربنا دخل همم لكن بس لعدم
الاستعداد وعدم الاكاديميه كمان في
السعوديه لازم يكون عندنا اكاديميه
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر وعلى وجودك معنا
من الخرطوم ناشطه رياضيات سمعها صلاح